hello everybody my name is markiplier
and today I'm gonna be showing you my
greatest shame
ever since I played insanity clicker you
guys have mentioned that it was a clone
of clicker heroes which is a game I
never played before so I thought what
the hell I'll give it a go it could be
fun
you guys wouldn't lie to me and so I got
it for my phone and has consumed my life
everything about my life is gone now and
it's been replaced by this stupid rat in
front of me and I gotta click him I
gotta kill him until he's dead and I'm
at such a high level now I've been
playing so long I mean it I know it
hasn't been that long since I played
insanity clicker I've been playing
non-stop on this like every waking
moment it's been open on my phone I had
to get a battery case for my phone for
it to last longer so that I can play
more it's [ __ ] this game is [ __ ]
I'm not sponsored by this game in any
way it's [ __ ] [ __ ] don't get it
it'll consume your life I've spent real
money on this but I love it but I hate
it but I love it oh I didn't even need
to spend real money on it gave me enough
free stuff anyway that I was able to get
it that's all gems that I've earned but
it's so [ __ ] god damn it I thought
and sanity clicker was cool just because
of the cool monsters that it showed by
this this [ __ ] Impala said it's a
possum it's not even a rat whatever [ __ ]
used yeah but anyway what I wanted to
show you is I'm at a high level I'm at
an absurdly high level where the numbers
don't even have any meeting anymore it
may seem like I have one thousand three
hundred and eighty-eight percent gold
that percent means does it mean one
octave de Cillian which is a lot it's
like 10 to the power of 18 I have no
idea it's a big number
and why is it number and god you [ __ ]
numbers but I kept chasing him a kids
job anyway so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna show you why I'm so freaking
consumed with it and I'm gonna I'm gonna
engage some storming power here and I I
I don't know what the most efficient
thing is but I just double my tap storm
for those of you know clicked a goal I
don't frickin know whatever and then I
tap with the fury of a thousand hell's I
gotta put on progression or else I'm not
gonna be able to beat this boss yeah
give me more heroes Souls primal mama
ferny bet whatever the [ __ ] you are it's
consumed my life it's gettin all my
friends cheetahs in love anymore
I don't take her outside she just poops
with reckless abandon of my bed anyway
once this is done I'm gonna restart the
game because that's the basic concept of
the game you played until you restart it
and then hopefully you get a little
farther than you did before and like I
have these these artifacts that help you
progress through the game which like
reduce the number of enemies you need to
kill reduce boss health stuff like that
that's all well and good and I even I've
got a bunch of gilded heroes which just
means they're slightly better than they
were before and you know I got all my
guys who are level way too freakin high
and [ __ ] money is due rugged expensive
and the reason I can't progress anymore
from where I am now is because my combo
is too low but if you notice at the top
it's the blue thing there the little
swirly windy symbol those are heroes
Souls so as you progress in the higher
levels you kill certain bosses that give
you hero's souls but only when you
restart your game over again isn't that
handy dandy tool so the guy that does
that is this guy a Menatep a men attempt
some Egyptian pharaoh at some point or
god I'm not a hundred percent sure on
that one don't quote me but when I start
this blink it will reset the game
and you will start a new game with 852
more heroes Souls it'll also keep a
rubies and ancients you will gain 8500
and 20% damage to all damage from heroes
souls so that sounds nice right hey
start the beginning but I was at level
570 [ __ ] that was a lot I just threw it
all away for a few more heroes Souls if
you're wondering what heroes souls are
spent on these [ __ ] with their [ __ ]
in their ball ass and their stupidity
and their usefulness and cool features
that allow you to kill a guy like this
week and he's dead how about that boy
boy boy boy boy boy boy boy boy and
they're dead and now I can get these
guys who are gonna kill them for me way
faster than they should die like
unbelievably quickly they just fall over
and die and then I gather more gold more
more more more more more more MORE until
you figure that maybe maybe it's time to
put down the game maybe it's time to not
let it consume you maybe it's time to
actually go outside and play with chica
my dog and and you know see another
human for the first time and stop
getting Chipotle delivered to my house
because that's a fun feature that I
learned and has caused me to never go
outside [ __ ] you
I got [ __ ] dough anyway so this is if
you're wondering if it gets like anymore
or what the hell I'm doing I've done
this so many times that and my my damage
has been multiplied so many times that
as I'm starting out I get to like level
150 before I can even see or even mmm
capable of clicking on anything before
it just dies and then you get more
golden and you hire more badasses that
can do more damage and then everything
is hunky-dory
it's
crazy this craziness is consuming you
can also level up by hundreds because
who has time to click am i right no one
no one has time to click so as you can
see I'm already at the billions of gold
level I'm getting literally billions of
goal and I'm smashing through bosses
like they're nothing if you came here to
see these cool creatures too bad they're
gone so I could there's also a
convenient feature to buy all upgrades
wink and then this happens they die more
and faster and better than before and
everything is great in my life stop
questioning the happiness I have I swear
like my computer my phone spends so much
processing power trying to calculate the
gigantic numbers that it actually causes
the battery to just lose out the size of
my thing not fast enough
oh man that boss almost lasted a few
seconds what is this [ __ ] I will not
have this in my house I get out of here
I will not have this in my house I will
not hear it my oh well get out of my
face God Aaron I'm good I'm getting me
I'll [ __ ] off I'm trying to be quick
about this and I'm doing everything
wrong
wink more damage more more MORE also the
combo system if you're wondering about
that in the top right basically as I'm
playing each time I click it adds to the
active combo so I can't close the app or
else it won't keep the combo it'll go
away and for every hit I get like 0.1%
more damage but you can click like
thousands of times in a session if I'm
actually serious about clicking which
i'll i'll show you my patented double
thumb technique literally just tapping
with my thumbs
III do the finger you know the double
tap with that tires my hand out I can
actually keep up the [ __ ] never mind
is not important information oh by the
hundreds I don't have time to waste on
you don't have time to waste on you I
don't have time to waste on you I wish I
had my life back I wish I had my whole
friends who needs friends when you have
the reward of ever exponentially
increasing numbers cuz that's all life's
about for all the [ __ ] I uh for all the
[ __ ] I give this game there actually is
a reason that it's addicting and it's
it's a satisfaction thing at least
that's what I feel right it's just very
satisfying Lee made like it's satisfying
to hit them cuz they do a little
animation it's very colorful
the gold sprays everywhere it's just
like it's designed that way and I guess
I can commend the developers for doing
that but I'm not gonna still not gonna
recommend this game even though at the
end of this video I'm gonna ask you to
join my clan so that I can get more
heroes Souls
okay so I've reached kind of the end of
the end of the heroes all have for a
while the next level is dread Knight and
I won't be able to get dread Knight for
a long time because dread Knight costs
the jump between like frost leaves costs
four hundred and three non-alien none
Ilion non-alien ya know de Cillian and
the dread Knight costs three more powers
of ten more than frost leaf and the
difference between those numbers may not
seem like a lot but it's a freaking huge
amount it'll be a hundred levels before
I can even get one dread Knight so for
now I just gotta kind of got to go with
the flow on the beginning here and I'll
lean up when you get to this level and
everything is getting all hunky-dory
that's a motive for resetting but I
don't want to reset yet because I want
more here level four where I reset and
then I'll be able to do more damage next
time and Lee relive this Wonder
bellowing all over again
but the only way to compete is these
guys level up yes you spend money on
level
but that's a linear process because and
if you don't know the difference between
linear and exponential process then you
won't be able to wrap your hands around
this uh but the the point of this is I'm
upgrading by levels of 25 because every
25 levels passed the last upgrade thing
you have and they each have individual
upgrade systems here that you can see
but every 25 levels passed the last
upgrade you have or I think maybe it
starts at 200 they will start
quadrupling their damage every 25 levels
they upgrade so it ends up that your
first few creatures that you have become
like your most damaging creatures after
like once it gets a while before the
next creature it gets involved but these
three guys right here Britney Ivan in
the tree beast they become the heaviest
hitters that I have they're doing
they're doing octillion or de Cillian
they're doing de Cillian levels of damp
they're doing n damage and compare that
to my frost leaf who's still only doing
o damage and if you don't know o is
before and in this scenario I believe
that's octillion which is two powers of
10 below n so if that's confusing
congratulations you're there with
everybody so if you're a nerd like me
who likes numbers this game's gonna
build it huh so up in the top left you
get more here Souls obviously the higher
you climb I was up over 500 before but
when you get to every five levels you
fight a boss and the boss has a chance
of being a primal boss and what that
means is the primal bosses are the ones
that offer hero souls every primal boss
or every hundred levels you go up which
takes a long time but the primal bosses
which are little rare give you hero
souls on your next like ascension that
it calls and that's how you eventually
climb higher just by keeping those hero
souls but if you want to spend money you
can actually use them to upgrade and get
more ancients and when you have the
ancients they have things like 60 more
seconds to boss timer more treasure
chest more chance of primal bosses more
dam
two critical clicks which is very good
this is actually a level 200 boss he's
not a primal but he still gives hero's
souls and that's how you're going hey
you can spend your rubies which you do
get a lot of when you're doing things
just because it's a very handy dandy to
be able to do them but you get a lot of
get a lot of rubies from achievements
and stuff and you can see the
achievements right there blah blah blah
okay that's not important cuz I don't
care about that well is important is
this any spam as hard as you can yep
this is fun the ideal of fun so anyway
that is clicker heroes if I had the time
I would be here for hours because that's
what I do in my normal day play this
frog I I know I'm giving you mixed
signals but I mean I do enjoy the game
but just be careful little consumers
well don't spend any money don't be
stupid like me don't do it it gives you
so many free rubies you don't need it
but still join my clan to join my clan I
have a clan by the name of the market
peeps if you want to join
I've got no members none and I'm trying
to beat these raid bosses and I'm gonna
kick this guy's ass so if you join
you'll see that this guy is still up and
you can fight him with me and then we
can fight him together so watch as I
kick his ass and try to beat him and in
a raid with your clan everyone takes
turns trying to beat the crap out of
this guy and get more heroes souls and
then everybody can collect once a day
and do all that sort of stuff right cool
ok so join up please find me I'm there
I'll add you I'll add anyone and ok
times up I did a lot of damage on him
but not as much as I wanted to do I did
a total of 750 6000 so that is all I
have to say about this game thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
enjoyed this well you must be as
obsessed about the game as I am but if
you didn't enjoy this
I'm so sorry that my crippling addiction
has gotten
you down in your day it gets me down to
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
yes does that mean you have a treasure
no it was filled with lies I'm gonna be
there inside your house I'm gonna be
looking in your windows watching you to
make sure you're safe when you sleep